okay it's your boy psychobabble we're
doing last luxuries get kanya here we're
gonna go rescue my mango juice stain you
know what I'm saying you know what I'm
saying okay okay let's go [ __ ] find
the mutant deal with her she's somewhere
on this floor floors buzzing with the
emitter signatures watch your Holograms
if it's who I think it is this is
Christine keep some recovery in what
looks like in the old world hotel room I
class two rooms exit sealed and yellow
doors are locked down security exact
same size and emitter signals are
lighting up all over this floor I'll do
what I can from here explores got
holographic security
latest tech how do I [ __ ] get out of
here we all pay for what we've done yeah
sure I'm sorry Sinclair sorry I should
have trusted ok why did you leave me
here y sin clip here Sinclair
I'm being recorded by the holographic
system came so far too okay [ __ ]
already passed up just Sinclair [ __ ]
yeah hey for what we've done she's open
with the work she [ __ ] open the door
[ __ ] [ __ ] shut ok thank you God ok
how can I do it thank you
original [ __ ] it Sarah
okay is it where's the [ __ ] radio
there it is she says okay okay I could
still [ __ ] here she's son lying oh oh
[ __ ] now Steve Gosch aside boy what can
I make here I nothin yeah I can't make
[ __ ] here because when I repairs go solo
yeah it sucks he can't like hockey [ __ ]
ouch
[ __ ] where to order gotta go [ __ ] right
ooh
I have a long [ __ ] i oughtta go
Claire Claire where did you go why did
you leave
oh there's
maybe I can go that way Sinclair
Sinclair the doors
[ __ ] we chop around there please help me
leave we all pay for what we've done I'm
so sorry Sinclair sorry I am no idea
what she's on about screaming to be let
out thank you Sinclair Sinclair I'm
trapped we please God the security
systems all ugly out there keeping we
all pay for what we are [ __ ] this is
insane oh my god ok ty
chef okay pickwick scribe jump you made
it their shoes
ha